[Musique]
un bon soir mardi 18 mai bienvenue dans
le 7-8 journal préparé par la rédaction
de tv 78 voici les titres de cette
édition
alors que les derniers chiffres parus
fin avril montraient un recul du chômage
au premier trimestre focus sur l'emploi
dans les yvelines
quels sont les secteurs et métiers qui
recrutent philippe quand directeur
territorial yvelines de pôle emploi est
notre invité est long mais également sur
cette opération de recrutement organise
en ce moment par l'enseigné lidl qui va
ouvrir très prochainement à voisins le
bretonneux
comme pour le football ou le handball le
cyclisme sur piste hausse aura aussi sa
ligue des champions lui ses hits
reichelt ligue a été présenté
officiellement ce matin et depuis le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
format six manches réparties sur six
semaines de compétition qui vont mettre
aux prises les meilleurs athlètes de la
discipline les détails à suivre
et si vous avez plutôt le pied marin
pourquoi ne pas passer votre permis
bateau des formations sont dispensées
sur les eaux du lac de l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines
elle s'adresse aux licenciés des clubs
nautiques franciliens mais avant de
développer ses titres c'est officiel
depuis hier il y aura à cette liste en
tout pour les élections régionales en
ile-de-france scrutin au programme et
les 20 et 27 juin prochain présentation
des candidats et des têtes de liste dans
les yvelines avec eléonore sinoquet
c'est officiel depuis lundi 17 mai au
soir les listes pour les élections
régionales ont été officiellement
déposée en ile-de-france cette liste
vont concourir pour la gouvernance de la
région capitale
tour d'horizon des têtes de listes
candidat à la présidence mais aussi des
postulants yvelinois valérie pécresse
repart présidente du parti libre et
présidente sortante du conseil régional
elle est candidate à sa réélection avec
la liste ile de france rassemblée elle
est également tête de liste dans les
yvelines
à ses côtés dans le département pas de
changement othman nasri premier vice
président sortant et conseiller
municipal d'opposition à trappes se
place en deuxième position suivi
d'alexandra dublanche adjointe au maire
à sartrouville est elle aussi
vice-présidente sortante du côté de la
majorité présidentielle c'est le député
du val de marne et rapporteur général du
budget à l'assemblée nationale lors en
sang martin qui conduira
la liste envie d'ile-de-france pour la
république en marche dans les yvelines
il a investi jean-noël barrot député
modem de la 2e circonscription en tant
que tête de liste
aurore bergé député de la 10e
circonscription se place à la deuxième
position
à gauche l'ancien journaliste et
actuelle adjointe au maire d'anne
hidalgo à paris audrey pulvar se lance
dans la bataille des régionales avec la
liste ile-de-france en commun investie
par le parti socialiste
elle a choisi d'y naba diop porte parole
du ps dans les yvelines et conseillère
municipale aux mureaux pour représenter
sa liste dans le département en deuxième
position ce sera eddie aït maire de
carrières sous poissy et conseiller
régional sortant
pas d'alliance avec le ps dont pour
europe ecologie les verts le conseiller
régional sortant et secrétaire nationale
du parti écologiste julien bayou se
présente à la présidence de
l'ile-de-france avec l'écologie
évidemment pour les ter yvelinoise
ghislaine tuner et conseillère régionale
sortante et ancien maire d v qu'on sera
tête de liste en numéro 2 benoît hamon
de génération ancien député des yvelines
et ancien candidat aux présidentielles
il a préféré e élevés plutôt que le ps à
l'autre bout de l'échiquier politique le
rassemblement national jordan barbe et
la vice président du parti de marine le
pen mais aussi député européen et
conseiller régional sortant a présenté
sa liste le choix de la sécurité dans
les yvelines pas de surprise le
responsable 60,18 du parti frontiste
laurent maurin et tête de liste suivi en
troisième position de cyril notre ancien
maire de mantes-la-jolie seules communes
d'île de france affilié rassemblement
national entre 2014 et 2020 à l'extrême
gauche de liste d'abord pouvoir vivre en
ile de france celle de la france
insoumise avec clémentine autain député
de la seine-saint-denis allié au parti
communiste français la liste investi
nelly duthu ancien maire de la verrière
et membre du comité exécutif du pcf
comme tête de liste yvelinoise sébastien
ramage conseiller municipal elle est
fille à guyancourt sera son numéro deux
enfin la septième et dernière lice faire
entendre le camp des travailleurs et
celle de nathalie arthaud porte parole
de lutte ouvrière dans les yvelines
jean pierre mercier l'ancien candidat
lutte ouvrière aux municipales 2020 à
poissy et tête de liste en numéro deux
une factrice à la retraite
hélène janis est dans l'actualité le
déconfinement qui se poursuit en france
et dans les yvelines avec demain
mercredi 19 mai la 2e étape qui sera
enclenchée à retenir le décalage du
couvre-feu de 19h à 21h il passe il sera
aussi question de la réouverture des
commerces non essentiels est des
terrasses des bars et restaurants des
lieux de culture les stades et les
arénas pourront également accueillir à
nouveau des événements avec public avec
à chaque fois mise en place de
protocoles et d'une jauge protocole
prochaine étape est également inquiète
au programme le 9 juin avec une nouvelle
levée des restrictions de main sur tv 78
une édition spéciale sera proposée par
la rédaction à l'occasion de cette étape
2 du déconfinement dans le même temps la
campagne de vaccination se poursuit dans
le département au 16 mai 373 1840 et une
personne a des reçus une première
injection dans les yvelines cinquante
mille de plus en une semaine la plus de
cent soixante trois mille complètement
vaccinés pour rappel la campagne est
ouverte aux plus de 50 ans aux plus de
18 ans avec comorbidités elle est plus
de 18 ans non prioritaires peuvent aussi
prendre rendez vous sur les créneaux
disponibles pour le jour même ou le
lendemain afin de ne pas gâcher deux
doses les evil qui vont compter bientôt
19 centres de vaccination de nouveaux
sites sont déployés sur le territoire
ils viennent s'ajouter aux 17 centres
déjà existants
elle a ouvert ses portes à bonnières sur
seine depuis le 17 mai l'autre sera
effectif à partir du 25 mai dans la
commune du chéné rocancourt
[Musique]
l'ouverture est prévue le 26 mai l
enseigne de supermarchés lidl ouvrira un
nouveau magasin à voisins le bretonneux
pour le faire fonctionner la direction
est à la recherche d'employés
le recrutement est en cours en
collaboration avec l'agencé pôle emploi
de guyancourt regarder ce sujet d'astrid
bergère l'ida la voisins le bretonneux
des ménages de quelques centaines de
mètres un supermarché plus grands qui
nécessite l'embauché de nouveaux
employés pour recruter liddell s'est
associé à pôle emploi le besoin a été
formulée pour quinze candidats formés et
recrutés à l'issue de la préparation
opérationnelle à l'embauché
donc nous avons organisé plusieurs
sessions de recrutement depuis décembre
2020 au total six ou sept sessions de
recrutement et on en a dédié
quelques-unes pour le public jeune et
cela s'inscrit dans le plan de relance
gouvernemental
un jeune une solution mais les
recrutements ne pousse un pas que les
jeunes et les contrats proposés par lidl
et pôle emploi elles sont variées
on recrute avec pôle emploi des profils
qui vend deux employés polyvalents
étudiants donc à partir de 7h 10h 14h
par semaine des profils employée
polyvalente 30 heures et également d
azur manager 36,75 une formation en
interne est prévu en fonction des
besoins
ici il n'est pas nécessaire d'avoir de
diplômes ni devenir du secteur
d'activité des supermarchés
moi j'ai été responsable d'un atelier
bon c'était complètement un autre
univers c'est dans la bijouterie
mais je voulais rester sur la même
dynamique gérer une équipe être
en étroite collaboration avec tous ceux
qui m'entourent
donc on m'a proposé cela et puis on a
fait les démarches nécessaires à 20 g
travaille dans la restauration
donc c'est un moment j'ai tort c'est un
peu pareil l'entente avec des clients au
début ça fait deux semaines
d'intervention appelé à gecina la
cantine et après j'avais une période de
deux mois au chili
[Musique]
je suis content si une partie de
l'équipe a déjà été recruté des postes
sont toujours à pourvoir dans ce nouveau
supermarché il ouvrira le 26 mai et
alors que les derniers chiffres du
chômage font état d'une baisse sur le
territoire des yvelines au premier
trimestre 2011 21 focus sur les secteurs
et métiers qui recrutent avec nous par
visioconférence philippe campe bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
territorial yvelines de pôle emploi
alors une enquête bmo pour besoins de
main d'oeuvre vient d'être publié elle a
été réalisée auprès des entreprises et
des établissements pour connaître les
projets de recrutement au niveau
national en région mais aussi dans
chaque département elle permet aussi de
connaître les secteurs et métiers qui
recrutent on s'est parfois philippe
campent les difficultés pour le
recrutement avec un décalage entre les
besoins des employeurs et aussi la
demande de la main d'oeuvre l'objectif
de cette enquête c'est justement
d'identifier ces difficultés pour les
pour les surpasser
oui effectivement c'est à la fois cette
enquête ça nous permet d'avoir la
visibilité sur les secteurs d'activité
qui recrutent et les métiers recherchés
et au regard des difficultés qui peuvent
être présentes et en tout cas donné par
certaines par certains secteurs
d'activité ça nous permet aussi de
prévoir l'achat de formation pour
pouvoir rapprocher l'offre l'offre et la
demande avec on vous imagine cette
stratégie aussi oui mais de faire
justement reculer le chômage allait vous
relancer là dessus je le disais il ya
une baisse qui a été enregistré au
premier trimestre 2010 21 dans le
département mais si on regarde le
différentiel sur un an là le nombre
demandeurs d'emploi a explosé à un + 7 %
en un an donc on imagine la stratégie
derrière c'est aussi de faire reculer ce
chômage alors la stratégie c'est
effectivement de faire reculer le
chômage
et pour ce faire on a effectivement une
stratégie de formation qui va nous
permettre de rapprocher l'offre et la
demande sur l'île de france et environ
140 mille places de formation qui sont
disponibles pour pour les demandeurs
d'emploi et pour les yvelines c'est
environ 14000 places de formation qui
qui sont disponibles et qui vont
permettre à des demandeurs d'emploi de
se former et de toux ou à occuper les
postes qui sont à disposition
aujourd'hui sur notre sur notre
territoire
pour cette enquête au niveau francilien
351 me l'établissement est interrogé
plus de 70000 ont répondu au
questionnaire soit un taux de retour de
20,1 pour cent qui maillent 25 bassins
d'emploi francilien est ce que c'est un
échantillon assez précié et fidèle
justement pour pour cette enquête ou
8,20 portant de répondants ça nous
permettre de fiabiliser effectivement le
résultat de cette enquête de travail et
aussi par extrapolation et donc de
d'avoir une vue précise de ces projets
de recrutement même si pour cette année
cette enquête est de prendre à prendre
aussi avec précaution puisqu'elle a été
réalisée entre octobre et décembre 2020
on était sur une période de confinement
donc avec des entreprises qui n'avaient
pas forcément une visibilité
suffisamment importante pour pour savoir
si elle devait ou pas recruter en plus
avec un certain nombre de secteurs qui
nous était largement touchés par ce
confinement l'hébergement la
restauration les transports le tourisme
l'aéronautique l'événementiel et bien
entendu des activités culturelles ou
récréatives
donc du coup à apprendre à apprendre
quand même avec précaution est bon on
voit que le de confinement se met en
place donc on peut aussi avoir de bonnes
surprises sur la deuxième partie de
l'année 2021 même si on a quand même 43
mille projets de recrutement sur sur le
département pour 2021
dans une période comme je viens de le
dire qu'il n'était pas forcément la
meilleure pour interroger les employeurs
mais qui donne quand même un peu de
visibilité
donc voilà il ya quand même matière à se
dire que on peut encore faire reculer le
chômage en 2021 au regard des projets de
recrutement qui sont à notre disposition
et de la stratégie de pôle emploi
d'offrir de la formation à ces
demandeurs d'emploi pour qu'ils puissent
occuper occuper ces postes
justement si on place le curseur sur les
yvelines vous nous avez révélé l'un
premiers chiffres de cette enquête avec
près de 40 3040 2473 plus exactement
projets de recrutement qui ont été
enregistrés sur les yvelines
il ya une baie 5 enregistrée par rapport
à l'année 2010 9 mai ou disais c'est
aussi des chiffres à prendre finalement
ils dépensaient puisque c'est une
enquête un peu particulière dans une
année particulière qui est celle de la
crise sanitaire
oui d'ailleurs on compare ces chiffres
avec l'année 2019 2019 et non pas 2020
on regarde la situation est sûre sur
2020 on sait aussi que sur nos
départements l'aéronautique
le secteur automobile est très présent
donc ça aussi et forcément un impact sur
les projets de recrutement du sur le sur
le département et qui peuvent expliquer
en plus de ce qu'on vient de dire
précédemment cette baisse constatée
quels sont les secteurs et les métiers
qui sont les plus recherchées dans les
yvelines
alors là on a vraiment des métiers afin
d'aider des emplois sur différents
secteurs 1 sur les sur les services sur
le second sur le sanitaire et social sur
le commerce sur sur l'industrie sur le
secteur de la construction avec le
bâtiment sur le bâtiment d'ailleurs au
l'emploi dans les yvelines et sur les
onze agences du département on organise
une semaine du bâtiment où les
demandeurs d'emploi peuvent rencontrer
les professionnels du bâtiment les
organismes de formation et donc pouvoir
la trouver d'aider des postes ou des
formations qui leur permettront de
trouver du travail dans un futur dans un
futur proche
on a quand même sur le début de l'année
2021 recruter
il ya eu 600 postes qui ont été pourvus
dans le bâtiment donc ce qui n'est pas
ce qui n'est pas négligeable
d'où aussi l'importance de ces
événements que l'on peut mettre en place
sur sur notre agence
et quand on parle de la de la formation
puisqu'on parlait de la formation chaque
mois aussi on organise un événement qui
s'appelle je veux me former en ile de
france et qui permet aux demandeurs
d'emploi de rencontrer des
professionnels et des organismes de
formation pour pouvoir occuper les
postes qui sont à disposition
on a eu un certain nombre oui oui vous
avez vous demandé parmi les métiers vous
venez nous présenter les secteurs plus
plus précisément quels sont les secteurs
qui rencontrent le plus de difficultés
justement dans le dans le recrutement
parce que c'est aussi ça le problème
oui alors là la difficulté de
recrutement elle est liée aussi à la
disponibilité de la main-d'oeuvre
d'où le travail de pôle emploi
d'interface entre les employeurs et les
demandeurs d'emplois et donc la
formation est un élément de réponse
on a aussi les contrats aidés qui sont
un élément de réponse pour les jeunes et
pour les jeunes est d'ailleurs dans
votre reportage sur l'idole ça a été
évoqué ces contrats aidés peuvent aussi
faciliter le recrutement sachant que le
chômage des jeunes est quand même
important sur ce au niveau national et
bien entendu aussi sur le sur le
département puisque le chômage a
augmenté de 19% pour le chômage des
jeunes en sur le premier trimestre 2002
1021 sur les différents les différents
emplois on a dans le secteur
médico-social donc 38 % des recrutements
globaux du territoire ont été réalisés
sur ce sur ce secteur avec les postes
d'infirmiers et d'aides-soignants ou
encore de dead médico psychologique
donc c'est 200 postes qui ont pu être
pourvus sur ce secteur sur ces métiers
en association avec l'agencé régionale
de santé
on a aussi une installation sur les
mureaux d'un foyer d'accueil médicalisé
qui s'adresse aux autistes et là aussi
il y à de nombreux postes à pourvoir sur
aides soignants infirmiers
ergothérapeute ou encore éducateur
spécialisé
donc voilà plein plein plein
d'opportunités
bâtiment l'a évoqué il ya la grande
distribution vous l'avez évoqué dans
votre robot reportage avec l'idole en a
eu aussi l'installation des parts marché
leclerc ali mais qui a permis l'embauché
de 78 collaborateurs dont 60% sont des
jeunes
vous avez parlé de l'idole à voisins le
bretonneux mais aussi de l'idole de
meulan qui va permettre de pourvoir une
trentaine de postes dont un tiers sont
pourvus par des jeunes on à l'industrie
je suis désolé on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien qu'il compte que cette enquête
allait servir un bien sûr à identifier
un ces secteurs métiers qui recrutent
dans les iem inadaptée aussi les
stratégies derrière pour pôle emploi
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
territorial yvelines de pôle emploi
la france compte un tiers de cyclistes
en plus depuis 2020 si certains ont
profité du confinement pour se mettre à
pédales et d'autres ont vu leur temps de
pratique diminuer ce nouveau magasin de
vélos à montigny le bretonneux ouvert en
mars dernier cherche justement à
s'adapter à ces évolutions de la
pratique
le reportage de bérangère bourgoin
ouvrir un magasin en pleine crise
sanitaire c'est le pari qu'a prigent il
verde en lançant le 17 mars 2021 son
magasin de vélos la cycle rice situé en
face du vélodrome nationale compétiteur
dans l'âme
on a ouvert est passionné on est sûr ça
va marcher un moment ou un autre
même si c'est vrai que les débuts sont
un petit peu difficile l'équipe
constituée de quatre cyclistes propose
plusieurs services
alors le conseil à l'achat de vélos bien
sûr selon la pratique de chacun
on va voir la partie réparation ateliers
pour tous types de vélos et puis après
on va voir des prestations un peu plus
particulière comme les études posturales
la clientèle sportive n'est pas encore
totalement au rendez vous à cause du
confinement notamment et la cidrerie
accueille beaucoup de cyclistes loisirs
en s'installant à saint quentin en
yvelines jean yves verdié compte aussi
sur une importante clientèle business
aujourd'hui on est dans une zone ici en
tout cas où il ya beaucoup de bureaux et
de sociétés aux alentours et puis on se
trouve aussi près d'une gare gare de
saint quentin en yvelines qui est qui
est très active et donc avec des gens
qui potentiellement peuvent avoir besoin
en particulier de petits vélos pliants
électrique ou pas pour pouvoir faire le
fameux derniers kilomètres pour se
rendre de la gare alors à leur lieu de
travail ou de la gare à leur domicile
semble le moyen de locomotion pour aller
au bureau qui me permet d'avoir un quart
d'heure de vélo le matin et un quart
d'heure 2-0 le soir en rentrant le
compliment ça a un peu diminué parce que
j'étais obligé de rester à la maison
pour travailler
donc j'avais plus longs déplacements
domicile travail en vélo par contre la
volonté de pratiquer le vélo sur saint
quentin reste toujours intense
le décompte ne m'en du 19 mai prochain
va certainement permettre aux adeptes du
vélo de se remettre en selle
que ce soit pour reprendre le chemin du
bureau les courses pour les plus
sportifs ou les promenades le week-end
c'était dans les cartons depuis
plusieurs mois le vélodrome national de
50 ans ni lead en yvelines va accueillir
les meilleurs pistards du monde à
l'occasion d'une nouvelle compétition
son nom la traque champion's league
alors a pour objectif de booster les
audiences du cyclisme sur piste
les précisions de mickeal et demi
d'euros c'est désormais officiel 20
novembre prochain le vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines va
accueillir les meilleurs pistards de la
planète à l'occasion de la ligue des
champions piste ici une toute nouvelle
compétition répartis sur six soirées
pendant six semaines avec 72 coureurs on
aura la crème de la crème parce qu'en
fait les coureurs doivent participent au
championnat du monde d'abord ils ont
rendu être qualifiés pour les
championnats du monde et aux
championnats du monde
seuls les meilleurs en fait se seront
qualifiés pour aller dans cette ligue
des champions
trente six hommes 36 femmes c'est la
parité c'est super quelque chose de
vraiment intéressant avec les meilleurs
athlètes du monde
cette nouvelle compétition a également
pour objectif de booster les audiences
de cyclisme sur piste à travers le monde
on est sur un format très court 2 heures
on vient d'abord au vélodrome
comment va venir voir une une pièce de
théâtre comme on va venir à voir un
match de foot comment va venir voir
autre chose on va venir voir un
spectacle un spectacle avec des athlètes
il y aura aussi de la musique du show
mais comme ça vers des formats très très
court un très compact
une nouvelle formule qui a convaincu le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le site
accueillera la deuxième manche
le but promouvoir la structure en vue
des jeux olympiques de 2024
la notoriété de la
visibilité mais également cela va
permettre de l'ouvrir à nouveau au
public on va retrouver la passion le
fait que ce vélodrome sera complet comme
il a été pour les championnats du monde
de cyclisme sur piste il ya maintenant
quelques années
en gros c'est le dynamisme la visibilité
pour que la fête soit encore plus
réussie le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines espèrent pouvoir
accueillir le maximum de public dans ses
gradins si la situation sanitaire le
permet en novembre toujours à saint
quentin en yvelines il est désormais
possible de passer son permis bateau la
formation est dispensée sur le plan
d'eau de l'île de loisirs et c'est à
destination des licenciés des clubs
franciliens justin brasier les plus
observateurs l'auront sûrement remarqué
des bateaux écoles navigue désormais sur
le lac est de l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines se former au permis
bateau sur place c'est donc maintenant
possible si la pratique est dispensée
sur un lac
les contraintes sont presque les mêmes
que celles en mer il y avait quand même
des conditions de mer aujourd'hui avec
le le le vent qu'on avait le début de
petites vagues au programme de la partie
pratique les manoeuvres à connaître pour
piloter un bateau à moteur mais aussi
l'apprentissage du matériel et des
responsabilités en tant que chef de bord
dont quelques matériel obligatoire à
avoir à bord au tout autant pour la
segard en tire la sécurité individuelle
que la sécurité collective et ensuite
fait céder de la manoeuvre la gestion à
haute vitesse pouvoir gérer des virages
à haute vitesse pour voir gérer un
arrivée de ponte ont repêché un homme à
la mer
prendre un coffre ce nouveau point
d'enseignement pratique permet d'élargir
l'accessibilité on a décidé en fait de
séquencer les formations sur l'année on
va essayer de faire six mois sur la
marne donc six mois plus vers l'est de
paris et les six autres mois plus vers
l'ouest de paris afin de
de pouvoir favoriser tous les clubs qui
veulent avoir accès à cette formation
organisée par nautisme en ile de france
la formation au permis bateau s'effectue
sur trois jours après validation de la
partie pratique les candidats doivent
passer l'épreuve théorique on aura accès
à un service informatique on pourra
répondre à tout un tas de questions qui
nous seront poussées des qcm des choses
comme ça et après on sera convoquée pour
passer officiellement le permis cet
enseignement est réservé aux licenciés
des clubs franciliens issus des quatre
ligues voile kayak aviron et ski
nautique
avant de vous laisser je vous le disais
tout à l'heure deuxième étape du
déconfinement enclenché demain mercredi
19 mai c'est la date choisie par le zoo
de thoiry pour rouvrir totalement au
public c'était déjà le cas depuis le 12
mai mais uniquement pour la partie et
safari qui se réalise en voiture pour le
respect des mesures barrières quelques
aménagements sont en place les points de
restauration sont ouverts à la vente à
emporter et les aires de pique-niqué
tendu billetterie accessible sur mobile
et internet
le port du masque est bien entendu
obligatoire dans l'enceinte du zoo voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité très belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]